I'm wearing a fake ring
I ordered it
well now Jillian's rocking the real deal
since the show Jillian's been expecting
it like everywhere so we went to the
place where we went for our first date I
had a playlist ready of our favorite
songs it was really romantic and I told
her today is not gonna be the day I'm
not gonna do it so he had a nice picnic
Jillian was a little sad and then we
came back to the apartment and we had
flowers arranged in a heart and and we
did it here I just wanted to be private
so I was very happy about that but Kevin
says a more elaborate proposal did cross
his mind we could maybe do this thing
for real yeah don't propose right now
before the show I said to her if I'm in
the finale I kind of want to propose on
TV and Jillian was like no I said I
would say no I love you so much I love
you so much I've missed you every second
I left this woman alone for basically
three months on her own I left my family
and friends and when you're locked away
and you don't have any contact with
anyone you appreciate those things way
more and as Kevin and Jillian planned
their big day will any BB Ken alums be
getting an invite we're gonna invite a
few people yeah yeah doing that you got
to think about keeping the drama away
from the wedding though you don't you
know you got to think about who's
sitting where or is everybody going to
get along what are they going to be
thinking a year after so it must be